do you think most women are happy being
alone 100
I think married women are the
complaining the most on the internet how
depressive they are and anytime now they
have an opportunity they're gonna
complain about being doing the the work
of the house you know like you know it I
think internet now is a place where
people complain most of the time and it
became sometimes boring on Tick Tock
when they start to dance and sometimes
to show
do you know what every time it's going
to be the iceberg top what they're going
to be showing on social media is not
their true life or not even one percent
of the true life so you cannot analyze
through social media